in this video we'll talk about the cree
Lock speed system this is a
site-specific recombination based
technology and this is frequently used
in molecular biology lab to knock out a
gene in Vivo mostly this system is
available in mice
so the biggest application of creelock
speed system is to create Gene Knockouts
that means deletion of a portion of the
gene but besides Gene knockout frankly
telling it can be used for gene
deletions
inversions or let's say translocation
reactions as well so creelock speed
system has diversification of
application so let's see how creeloxp
system actually works
so creelock space system usage uses the
site-specific recombination system and
the cree enzyme is actually a
recombinant it's a tyrosine-based
recombinase
so in this particular tree log space
system you have a so called cream ice
which has which is crossed with a lock
speed mice and Bam in F1 generation you
have The Knockout how it is the
happening so in the cream house you have
the cree recombinase coding sequence
underneath a tissue specific promoter
for example if the tissue specific
promoter is expressed in brain the cree
would be expressed only in the brain now
the lock speed Mouse is generated in
such a way that it has specific
sequences
which is flanked by log SP sites Lock
speed sites are necessary for this site
directed uh recombination reaction so
Lock speed site in this example is
flanked by two exons of a particular
Gene that we want to knock out
so create common up and Crossing these
two thing in the F1 generation the mouse
would have the clearly communis produced
and that is only produced in the brain
in this case because the promoter is
active in the brain free recombinase is
getting uh produced and binding to
specific log SP side on the particular
Gene of interest and as a result it is
fluxing out a portion of these Gene so
in this case three exons are now deleted
fluxed out and the result is basically a
knock out three Exon is deleted in this
case a deletion mutant is created
now whether it is deletion or inversion
all this thing matters on the
orientation of the lock speed site if
the lock speed site is oriented like
this it would result in fluxing out or
deletion of a portion of the construct
so what is site specific recombination
actually site specific recombination as
the name suggests this is a
recombination reaction which is directed
by specific sequences
which is known as recombination
recognition sequence let's say so how
this recombination reaction Works
obviously it is enzyme based so cream
enzyme is basically a tyrosine-based
recombinants so B tyrosine basic
companies or serine basic combinase it
would have a hydroxyl group which is a
source of nucleophile it would attack
the phosphate backbone and create a
enzyme DNA hybrid eventually it would
create the Strand passage and the
reaction by this if you want to learn
more about site specific recombination
and how does it work you can click on
the video in the I button or in the
description
but anyway let's see how this Cree Mouse
are generated or the lock speed Mouse
are generated so the creek construct is
actually injected into the fertilized
egg so in the Pro nucleus of the
fertilized egg
so the click construct has tree
recombination pre-recombination sequence
underneath the tissue specific promoter
and this is loaded onto a transposon
based Vector such that it can stably
integrate into the genome at very early
stages now that zygote is injected in
the mouse the zygote would eventually
form the embryo it would develop like a
normal embryo and ultimately this mouse
would give rise to the transgenic cream
Mouse and the the transgenic line is
born it would be now crossed and
maintained as a crease stock
similarly using a similar transgenic
approach one can generate the lock speed
Mouse as well
okay now let's talk about the
applications of Cree logspy system
this has a widespread active
applications one of the first
application is creating knockouts
so people call it conditional knockouts
let's say you want to understand how a
gene X regulates brain development so
obviously you you should make a muted
from a classical point of view but what
happened is due to the mutation of Gene
X the animals die they didn't even
survive to the mature State why is that
maybe Gen X is required for some
important function in the liver so that
is why it is lethal so but your question
is dedicated to the brain you want to
understand that what really happens when
Gen X is selectively gone in the brain
not in other portion of the body
that is why pre-lock speed system is
really useful
because lock space system gives you a
spatio temporal control
by using the tissue specific promoter
and that is how the conditional knockout
concept is coming into the picture
so the tree has the promoter which is
tissue specific and the lock speed side
flanking the gene is present in all the
portions but the recombination reaction
is happening especially in those tissue
where tree is active
now this is a spatial control but what
happens to the temporal control in order
to have a temporal control the cree ER
T2 system is used in the cree ert2
system we have a Cree ER Mouse in this
ER Mouse along with the cree uh sequence
the ligand binding domain of estrogen
receptor is also cloned
so in the protein State you have a Cree
and estrogen receptor ligand binding
domain fusion protein normally without
the presence of estrogen or tamoxifen
so what happens is the entire receptor
complex is inhibited by H the by HSP 90.
so in this case you can see it in the
blue so even if Cree is present in this
case cannot act because it is inhibited
by a heat shock protein but when we
inject this same Mouse with tamoxifen
which acts like a ligand for these uh
estrogen receptor it leads to the
dissociation of the HS heat shock
protein 90 that leads to the cree
activity that means whenever we inject M
we can start the creativity it gives us
a nice temporal control when the when
the recombination reaction is happening
so the tissue specific promoter here is
giving us the
spatial control and amoxifen injection
is giving a temporal control thereby
using three logspeed system one can
achieve a spatial temporal control of
gene expression or let's say Gene
knockout
second
the screen lock space system can be used
to do linear stressing experiments or
simply put label some particular cell
types or category of cells let's say you
have a particular reported Gene in this
case TD tomato it can be gfp as well
anyway the reporter Gene has a stop
cassette marked here in green and it is
flanked by the log SP sites so normally
in this particular Mouse there would be
no reporter expression because there is
a stop cassette right
but when it is crossed with a tissue
specific
promoter containing Cree
it would be activated upon creamediated
recombination so cremediated
recombination would flux out the stop
cassette and now the entire coding
sequence would be transcribed and
translated production of reported Gene
is happening that would label specific
cells in red
and this is how we can really label a
specific subtype of neuron or let's say
a class of neuron in a mouse brain or
any other organ it only requires us
organ specific or tissue specifically
now um
using this sequence you can label sub
population of neurons for example let's
say you want to understand what happens
in what happens into the dopaminergic
neuron when you treat it with a drug or
some kind of mutation happen what
happens to selectively the dopaminergic
neuron population not other neurons so
in this case you have a tyroxine
hydroxylase promoter which is very
selective to dopaminergic neuron which
produces dopamine
anyway underneath that you have a
membrane bound
Serie gfp reporter
and again it's a stop flux reporter that
means it has a stop codon in the
reporter Gene
supremediated recombination would level
those cells which are dopaminergic it
won't level any cells which are
serotonergic or glutamate energy because
this particular promoter is only active
in dopaminergic cell now obviously this
particular reporter line is marking all
the dopaminergic neurons so we can
quantify the morphology of these neurons
so let's say we have a control set and
we have treated it with a drug XYZ let's
say and now we want to understand what
happens to the neuronal morphology what
happens to the neuronal properties all
these questions can be answered using
the cree logsp system these are only few
applications that I have elaborated in
but there are many other applications
which can be used for example
neurobiologists frequently want to
understand what is the neuronal activity
status and that's why they use a calcium
reporter in Vivo and this is known as a
gcam 6 reporter if you want to learn
more about calcium Imaging or G cap you
can get it in my I button or the
description box
anyway in the gcamp mouse what happens
there is a stop cassette at the end
Terminus of the G cam sequence gcamp is
a genetically encoded calcium sensor so
when there is a clean mediated
recombination
it leads to the transcription and
translation of G cap so gcam fluores is
when there is calcium present in the
neuron and it indirectly reports the
neuronal activity so when the neuron is
firing g-camp would also show enhanced
fluorescence
using this approach and combining it
with two Photon microscopy
um a scientist can actually look at the
specific layers of neuron in the mouse
brain while they are behaving or
undergoing some kind of drug treatment
so this is how creel oxy system is very
useful for multitude of application
so I hope this was useful so in summary
I'll say what is screen lock speed
system we learned it's a site
specifically communist based technology
what is the use of creelock speed system
it can be used in many ways but one of
the most popular application is creating
deletion insertions or translocations in
a particular Gene of Interest
and what is the advantage of pre-lock
speed system yes we can control the
creelock speed system in spatio temporal
manner that means we can control Gene
deletion spatially as well as
temporarily
but what is the disadvantage of the
screen lock speed system sometimes what
happens is the free Lock speed system is
leaky that means even if a particular
promoter is not expressed in a
particular tissue Cree is active in that
tissue so that is a often problem using
free Lock speed system so I hope this
was useful you can get more notes and
flashcard in my Facebook page or in my
Instagram page links are provided in the
description you can support my channel
using super thanks option your small
contribution as small as let's say 50
rupees would be really useful for us you
can pay via PayPal paytm or UPI
see you in the next video